[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JULIEN FINLAY: So
as I said, this talk
is about body positivity.
This talk is about online hate.
And this talk is
also about know how
to create online, how
to absorb what you
receive when you create online.
You may see three
people on stage.
You were expecting
maybe a fourth one.
But things happen, and
Stephen cannot join us today,
unfortunately.
He's supporting another, I
think, broadcasting radio show
that's happening at the
same time, which is fine.
It gives us more time to
talk and meet each other.
So yeah, so as we think of
the tech companies as a whole
and what they bring
to the minorities,
they can be seen as a connector.
They can be seen as a medium.
If you think of
YouTube, how they
have videos to explain
and to show to trans kids,
hey, how to do
stuff, how to prepare
your voice, and et cetera.
Or how do you think about
WhatsApp as connecting
in some countries, like
Chechnya or Brazil,
when you actually-- it's the
only media, social media,
it would be active.
Or if you think of dating
apps, like Grindr and et
cetera, where you
would put yourself out
there but not sure
how you receive
what's going to be back.
So that's on my mind today.
I want to talk about creation.
I want to talk about the
hate and the backlash.
I also want to mention this
week is Trans Awareness Week.
And I'm delighted having a
diverse panel, willingly.
Like we had Bella
in June, who is
a bisexual-- amazing,
fierce woman.
And she is white.
And this is a white panel.
But I also want to
have diverse voice.
So then again, I'm
very happy having
this group present on here.
All right.
So we're here.
We have time.
We'll have some wine.
We'll have some
non-alcoholic Prosecco.
I couldn't make
this sentence gayer.
And yeah, so that's that.
I think I can leave you all
introduce yourselves and share
whatever you want to do
right now in your intro.
Aoife, go ahead.
AOIFE MARTIN: Hi.
My name is Aoife Martin.
I'm a senior software
engineer with MasterCard.
And I transitioned
about two years ago.
So since then, I've been
quite an outspoken advocates
for trans rights and
for trans people.
And whenever I can, I sort of
volunteer my time to do talks.
I write articles
about trans issues.
And I'm quite active on social
media about trans issues.
So yeah, I'm quite passionate
about trans rights.
I think I was just speaking
to Finley in the green room,
I suppose you would
call it, back there.
And trans rights are now where
gay rights were 20 years ago.
So I think we still
have a long way to go.
I mean, we've come a
long way in this country.
But there's still an
awful lot of work to do.
And it's a pleasure to
be here and to be talking
with you guys about this.
And hopefully, we'll all
learn something together.
And we'll have a
bit of fun doing so.
JULIEN FINLAY: Welcome.
How about you, Finlay?
We had to change the
chairs for reasons.
FINLAY WILSON: A little bit.
JULIEN FINLAY: It's true
what they say, is it?
FINLAY WILSON: Let's
not get into that.
That's a very gendered question.
If I ask this to the
females in the room, what
do you wear underneath, I
would get in a lot of trouble.
So you watch yourself, Aoife.
So my name is Finlay.
I am a yoga teacher in Scotland.
I also am on social media a lot,
more than I probably should.
I create content
for BBC The Social.
So I create little videos about
things that are motivating me.
But more importantly,
the BBC have
allowed me to have a voice
to speak about whatever
I want to speak
about, which is great,
even though sometimes
they tell me to shut up--
a lot.
But that's fine.
I just take to my Instagram and
write the same thing anyway.
And that's obviously opened up a
whole realm of social scenarios
that are incredibly anti-social.
I've kind of come out of
that, of being a creative that
does things online that
is visually present online
but also who shares their
relationship openly online.
That came out as if my
relationship is open.
That is not true.
So those of you who are
going to Instagram me,
and it's like, oh,
I thought Instragram
is an open relationship.
No.
JULIEN FINLAY: [INAUDIBLE]
on Instagrammers.
FINLAY WILSON: That always,
always, even this morning--
anyway, that's another topic.
Thank goodness for the filter
folder of the DM on Instagram.
Where was I going with that?
JULIEN FINLAY: You
were opening your--
FINLAY WILSON: Yeah.
So I share my daily interactions
with my partner, my dogs,
and things online.
And I don't think it's
anything exceptional.
But it is a thing of visibility.
But when people go after
that and try and attack it
for whatever their
bigoted reasons are,
I will not stand for it.
So maybe that's a thing.
JULIEN FINLAY: Well, it's
the thing today, definitely.
All right.
So I come from an
academic background.
And I think before talking
about all these words,
I'd like to just pause
and have some definitions.
So when we talk
about cyberbullying,
we talk about using
the technology
to harass, embarrass,
or target a person.
Usually, we mention
cyberbullying
when it's referred to
young kids or teenagers.
But we can also talk
about cyber harassment.
And it is a crime.
And there's legal consequences--
to which extent, we
will discuss these.
Regarding online
hate, that's just--
name calls itself.
You know, it's a
speech online full
of hate to attack based on
attributes, these attributes--
religion, ethnic
origin, sexuality,
et cetera, or gender.
And finally, body
positivity, which I guess
is the one we'd
like to focus more
about at the end of the day.
There's hate.
There's harassment.
But there's also great
things out there.
And there's also great support.
And there's great movements.
And this is something I
would like also to tackle.
All right.
I want to kick off with
a nice, relaxing video.
You can see I'm in a very
relaxing state of mind today.
I don't know why.
I may collapse.
Haven't taken Valium
yet, but let's go.
So you OK if I
show this, Finlay?
FINLAY WILSON: Aye, yes.
JULIEN FINLAY: So that's what
brought Finlay here somehow.
It's a domino effect.
FINLAY WILSON: It will only
give me one view, though.
JULIEN FINLAY: Oh, yeah.
All of you, connect
your phones and give him
more like then 10 views.
All right.
So let's have a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CALMING MUSIC PLAYING]
FINLAY WILSON: I don't
know [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
[END PLAYBACK]
JULIEN FINLAY: Nothing
levels the playing field more
than everyone in the room
having just seen your arse.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIEN FINLAY: Anyway, so--
pleasure.
So you saw that video--
FINLAY WILSON: That's
[INAUDIBLE] version.
JULIEN FINLAY:
--which is online.
But it has been seen more than
50 million times, that video.
And it is jolly.
It is motivating.
It has good words--
connectivity, connectedness,
positivity-- on it.
It did link to homophobic
slurs and attack.
It has driven you
out of your house.
So how do you feel about this?
When this beautiful
video was made,
you were not expecting such
a consequence, I assume.
FINLAY WILSON: Not to
the extent that I got--
we were prepared.
So when we launched into
creating content for BBC,
it was just like
little segments.
You record it yourself.
You edit it yourself.
You send it in.
And they put it out there.
We were told there would
be some negative stuff that
would come back.
There would always be trolls.
And we were told,
like, oh, we can always
speak to them about it.
But it actually turned out
to be 72 million views later,
that's not going to be
all positive people that
are watching that, especially
the second one, which
had a little bit more
man-on-man action.
That one got a lot more negative
feedback and a lot less views.
Because people were suddenly
uncomfortable because they saw
us physically connecting.
Now he's a straight guy.
But as soon as they saw even
just my hand on his shoulder,
the tone was
completely different.
And actually, it
was more that one,
which was released maybe about
a month and a half after.
That's the one that I think
started the campaign of people
getting in touch directly and
being very abrupt, to the point
that the people who were
living in my building
took it upon themselves to
threaten to not only hurt me,
but also threatened
to kill my dog.
And then it was failed to be
processed by the police, who
failed in their investigations
and didn't really look
into it, even though,
ironically, it
was Hate Crime Awareness
Week in Scotland,
that the police sanctioned.
They were the ones putting
the posters everywhere.
They did nothing.
And I was told to shut up by
the chief of Scottish police
about the issue.
So obviously, I didn't.
I went public on BBC The
Social and made it very clear.
I read parts of the letter out
and basically asked people--
well, it was more that
I was sick of everyone--
the police, the people I
was speaking to-- saying,
we didn't think this happened
anymore, as if that made it OK,
as if, like, no, this
doesn't happen anymore.
This is an exceptional
circumstance.
But when I then took
the list of, well, this
is what's being
said online, this
isn't an exceptional
circumstance.
This is not a one-off scenario.
This is every day.
But now it's at my
actual doorstep, threats
being made against
even my animal,
you know, my little
furry friend.
That's not OK.
That then escalated.
So in the same
building, I started
dating my partner, who
is still my partner, not
an open relationship.
And his tires got slashed
outside our property.
And all the bays are marked.
So they knew which
one was our car.
So our tires got slashed.
It never got investigated.
They never looked into it.
Nobody came round to check.
We reported it, but
nothing happened.
So this feeling
of oppressive hate
was strong enough
that I had to leave
home, move somewhere else.
And that is very--
it feels very disgusting.
But it certainly hasn't
stopped me creating content.
Because it wasn't the content's
fault. And it wasn't my fault,
either.
It was bigotry.
It was lack of education.
But it was also a
lack of people's--
without using the
term mindfulness
to see the damage
that they're doing.
JULIEN FINLAY: I hear you.
I'm sorry it happened to you.
FINLAY WILSON: Well,
the strangest thing
is the strangest allies
come out of the woodwork.
There's a guy who I teach at
my yoga studio who I was like,
ah, did not want to teach him--
complete prejudice.
I'm just going to go
right ahead and say it.
But when you see a guy
come in, muscle belt,
shaved head, like legit SS
Nazi tattoos on his arms,
you would--
you know?
I'm on his kill list.
I usually would step
back and be like, oh.
He was the one driving
me home at night
to make sure I got home
safe, so unexpected allies.
He is obviously no longer
a Nazi sympathizer.
He's very much a very
changed creature.
But--
JULIEN FINLAY: Let
me go back on the--
FINLAY WILSON: --he's an
interesting little social
feature, who yoga and
mindfulness actually
brought him to stand as an
ally for me, which was lovely.
JULIEN FINLAY: OK.
I think Nazian allyship--
FINLAY WILSON: That's
a different thing.
JULIEN FINLAY: --could
be a great talk.
[LAUGHTER]
But thank you for
sharing this, Finlay.
And when I think of reaction
of putting yourself out there,
I know Aoife, you had
a different experience
whenever you came out at work.
I'd like you, if you're OK,
sharing this story of you
coming out at work
at MasterCard,
but also somehow comparing this
reaction you had when you came
out at work to when you
were maybe coming out,
talking more about
your coming out online.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah, sure.
So it was about two years ago.
Actually, it was 2016,
where I came out as Aoife.
I mean, I spoke to my HR
manager before I came out.
And at that time,
I h ad been working
with MasterCard for about
four years at that stage.
And so I told her
that I was transgender
and that I wanted to transition
within the workplace.
And needless to say, I
think this was quite a shock
for my HR manager.
And she'd be the first
person to admit that.
And I think she
said at that time
that she didn't know if we
had any policies in place.
She'd never encountered this
in her HR career before.
She'd never
encountered anybody who
was transgender and didn't know
basically how to sort of handle
the situation.
But the first thing she did
was she gave me a hug and says,
yep.
OK, we'll do this.
Let's get through this week.
And we agreed that we
would meet every week
to sort of plan out a sort of
a roadmap, where things that--
who would I tell, when would
I tell them, badge changes,
email address changes, all
these sort of little things
that you have to think about
if you're coming back to work
from one gender to another.
And you know, I'd
love to say that it
was a difficult process,
and we had to fight battles,
and we knew we were
really strong about it.
But to be honest,
it was quite easy.
I mean, changing my
name on the system
was just me logging into one
of our software applications
and just changing my name.
And it just filtered down
through the system, you know?
So it was quite easy
in that respect.
And we agreed that I would come
back to work in January, 2016,
as Aoife.
And I said, well, who
do we need to tell?
What way do we want
to handle this?
And we agreed that I would tell
some colleagues and some team
members.
I would tell my manager.
But that was it.
We didn't need to
tell anybody else,
because it was nobody
else's business.
You know, if somebody
comes out as gay,
you don't go, oh, let's announce
it to the entire company.
So there was no
big announcement,
that, oh, Aoife is
coming back in January.
And she will be a
different person.
So it was quite easy
in that respect.
I mean, also word of
mouth will get around.
The grapevine will do its thing.
And people are going
to find out, so--
JULIEN FINLAY: And
when you come back?
AOIFE MARTIN: And when I
came back in January, 2016,
I clearly remember
my first day back.
I was very, very nervous.
And only a handful of people
knew this was happening.
And I got into the
office very early.
And I sat behind my monitor,
just like I sort of just
crouched down and just sort of
hoped most people wouldn't even
notice.
And a friend of mine said,
well, I hope your day is just
weirdly normal.
And I said, if it's
weirdly normal,
I'll be happy with
that, you know?
And a few people come
over throughout the day
who had known this was
happening, just to wish me luck
and to say, well
done sort of thing.
And then when I came back
from lunch on that day,
there was a big bunch of
flowers that my HR manager
had arranged to send, which was
such a lovely, lovely touch.
I wasn't expecting it at all.
And it said, from
everyone at MasterCard,
accept these flowers
to us, which was
such a lovely, sweet message.
And I took a photo
of the flowers.
And I put this on Twitter.
And the reaction was huge.
We had an interview with
the "Irish Independent."
We spoke on a program on
Newstalk for a documentary.
And it just went viral.
So that's where my
activism started
to kick in and where I
thought, OK, I can actually
make a difference here.
I can actually try and
speak about transitions
and make people aware
of these issues.
So their of reaction
was very, very positive.
Online reaction has been
negative and positive as well.
So it just varies from who's
sort of doing it, you know?
I mean, I can talk about
the negative stuff now
if you want or--
JULIEN FINLAY: Please do.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah,
so I initially,
before I came out in
MasterCard, I sort of
came out on Twitter before.
And that was hugely
positive for me.
And a lot of people were
very, very accepting.
But then, of course, there are
people who aren't as accepting.
And like I remember
once, waking up one day
and just checking
my Twitter feed.
And somebody had a
posted a photograph
of me, one of my pictures,
and with the word man scrolled
across it, and just had sent
that to all of her followers.
You sort of go--
so I sort of took
the same photograph
with the word man
scrawled across it
and wrote W-O in front of it.
And I posted that
once to all followers.
And it's quite hurtful.
It's something you have to
build up a thicker skin about.
Because there's a
lot of negativity
out there, especially
towards trans people,
especially more so in the
UK than in Ireland, I think.
And there's an awful lot of
online hate about trans people
at the moment, a
lot of negativity
in the press about trans people.
And I think we need
to combat that.
And I get misgendered
all the time.
I get called he.
I get accused of
all sorts of things.
But at this stage, I've
got a pretty thick skin.
You don't go through
life being trans and not
getting a thick skin by
the end of it, you know?
JULIEN FINLAY: And that's, as
I say, you really speak out.
And you accepted that skin.
And you actually are making it--
you're hardening it
by defending others.
To all of you, who
has, to some degree,
ever experienced online hate or
cyberbullying or harassment--
maybe not to their
extent, but something
you did not like reading
or seeing or receiving?
Yeah.
So it happens.
It doesn't have to be changing
your name or your badge
or having 50 million
views on you,
but to create such a backlash.
You both talk about
campaigns against yourselves.
And the Google part of your
campaign, it's something
you set up.
You think.
You plan.
Would that be the case for
you as in a group of people
or a person who really take
their time, their money,
their energy to be hateful
and use internet as a media
to develop that hate?
FINLAY WILSON: I'm not sure
it necessarily-- so campaign,
almost just describing more than
one person kind of getting in
on it, not necessarily they're
spending money behind it.
But certainly, I will see
people leave incredibly damaging
comments and will
tag friends who
obviously share those views.
And then the bombarding starts.
And that can usually start
to really snowball things.
Because you try and
block one of them.
And then the accounts
start replicating.
So that can be
incredibly frustrating.
But there is a resilience that
you have to develop to that.
I mean, I ended up
having an argument
against Piers Morgan, which
I suppose was his campaign.
Because he was
trying to diminish--
he re-shared the video about
male suicide and depression
that my twin brother and I
created and told us to man up.
And that was him
using his platform
in a really negative way.
Because we were speaking
about coming out issues.
We were speaking about that
sort of identity crisis
but also about male
suicide and depression.
And he could have used his
platform for good, sharing it.
But instead, his campaign was
one of hate and derogatory.
So it's not just the
little grunt trolls
that you need to watch out for.
There are some people who really
do have campaigns against us.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
And there is an organization in
the UK called a Woman's Org--
awomansplace.org, I
think it's called.
And they're very
much anti-trans.
And the UK at the moment--
I don't know if you're
aware-- is trying
to change their Gender
Recognition Act to allow
trans people to self-identify.
And this is something we
brought in in Ireland in 2015.
And it hasn't caused
any issues whatsoever,
whereas this year, there's
been a campaign in the UK
to push back.
The UK government opened
up a consultation process.
And this awomansplace.org has
had meetings in Parliament
and has set up meetings in
town halls around the country
to advocate against changing
the Gender Recognition Act
and to not allow trans people
in the UK to self-identify.
And they tried to set up a
meeting in Dublin to actually,
to come over here and set
up a meeting in Dublin.
And they were pretty much
given the short shrift.
And a lot of Irish feminists
wrote an open letter,
saying that TERF
says that they're--
TERF, that stands for
Trans-Exclusionary Radical
Feminist.
And so they wrote a letter,
saying TERF says, and saying,
you're not welcome
in this country.
This is Ireland.
We support trans
people in this country.
And we don't want you
guys coming over here.
And it was signed by well over
1,000 cisgender feminist women
who were pro trans rights.
So it's great.
It was great to see
that, that these guys
weren't welcome over here.
But they're quite
prominent in the UK.
And they're getting a lot
of attention by the media.
JULIEN FINLAY: How does it--
when we talk, when we
think of this hate,
when we think of
the slurs, and sure,
you have a hard
skin, both of you.
And you would also help
other people, I'm sure,
who contact you and
may not have the voice
or may not have your courage.
So you are also counseling them.
How does it affect yourself?
How do you cope
with that in terms--
you mentioned mindfulness.
But it is a hard road
to take on when you just
want to be yourselves and
live on with your lives.
How do you feel, both of you?
AOIFE MARTIN: [INAUDIBLE].
FINLAY WILSON: Sure.
Certainly, I think to think
that the reaction is downplayed,
like, yes, I'm here.
Yes, I'm sort of standing
up and doing all this stuff.
But when these
things come in, there
is still that
overwhelming sensation
of not wanting to leave the
house, of feeling completely
slimed, and having that
really frustrating moment
of questioning yourself.
And that's the worst
part, that worst part,
where actually your
self-acceptance wavers
in the face of that.
And that, for me, is where
my yoga practice comes in.
Because I almost need to
reset my Finlayism before
I then leave the door again.
So for me, my morning
yoga practice,
my time to do that reintegration
work so that when I go out,
I don't just see the first
straight person I see,
think that they're going to
attack me and try and kill them
first.
Whew.
Yeah.
Don't do that.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
I mean, I think that
that's a very good point
about accepting yourself.
Because there is a lot
of negativity out there.
And I always say the bravest
step a trans person can take
is stepping across
that threshold,
stepping outside
the door in public--
not even just the first
time, nearly every time.
Because you're putting
yourself out there.
You are possibly visibly
trans and open to negativity.
I read all sorts of
crappy comments online.
And while I'm quite a
thick-skinned person,
it's the sheer volume
of it that just
chips and chips and chips away.
And there are days where I
just god, oh, I just can't
face going outside the door.
And I don't want to
go outside the door.
But I have to.
I have to get up.
I have to go to work.
I work in an office where
everybody knows I'm trans.
And everybody is cool with that.
But it's still not easy.
You know, it's still a
difficult thing to do.
And I think that it's
just the sheer sort of--
as I was saying, just the
sheer volume of that hate.
It's not just, I can
handle one comment.
I can handle a
number of comments.
But when it's just drip,
drip, drip, that drip feed,
eventually, it does chip
away at you sometimes.
And I'm aware of
trans people in the UK
who haven't left their
house in months, they said,
because the negative
reaction from media,
from people on the street,
from all sorts of things.
And it's a pretty toxic
environment at times, you know?
FINLAY WILSON: We were talking
about it in the green room.
I teach in some of the island
communities in Scotland.
And somebody comes
to me and said
they hadn't seen a single
living person in over 30 days
because they're trans
on this Scottish island.
And they just say they feel like
they just can't go anywhere.
And so they just choose
to not see anyone.
But I think the comments
that come in almost directly
to our social media, they do
that almost daily chipping
away.
We do that small
practice of reintegration
and then go back out
the door that morning.
But the more oppressive
thing is seeing the things
in the larger picture.
And we see America,
rights getting
stripped away left, right,
and center, and thinking,
when's it going to come here?
When is this going
to happen here?
When am I going to get
discriminated against in a shop
again?
JULIEN FINLAY: Do you feel
supported sometimes by others?
Or it's you against a big
wave that you may not--
FINLAY WILSON: That's where
the education comes in.
Because even my family,
every single one of them,
straight, generations of
frustrating straight people.
And that's not me saying
that if you're straight
that you're frustrating.
But they live under
this shell, this bubble,
where they're like, no, none
of that happens anymore.
You're overreacting.
And they don't get
why I get angry.
They don't get why I get upset.
They don't get why sometimes I
phone my mum and I'm in tears.
I'm like, do you see
what is happening here?
Do you see how the rainbow world
is burning around the planet?
When I go and teach in places
like Indonesia to be told,
you need to really dial
everything you do down,
which see when you teach in
pink leggings, that's hard.
That's hard.
It's hard to do, all right?
To not feel safe--
I feel relatively
safe in Scotland.
When I was teaching in Texas,
I did not feel safe, all right?
When I was teaching in
Indonesia, I didn't feel safe.
But I kind of found
like a gay community who
were like the rebel faction.
It was nice to kind
of hang out with them.
But that cloud of
oppression isn't going away.
And actually, that one saps
me more than the daily.
JULIEN FINLAY: Do you want to
add something to this, Aoife?
AOIFE MARTIN: Sorry.
I lost my train of thought.
What was the question again?
[LAUGHS]
JULIEN FINLAY: Basically if
you feel supported, if you
have people there for you?
AOIFE MARTIN: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIEN FINLAY: If you
[INAUDIBLE] to combat?
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
That's a good question.
I mean, I have a lot of friends
who are very, very supportive.
Most of my friends would
be cisgender women.
And they've totally accepted me.
And we go for coffee.
We meet.
We go for meals, et cetera.
And it's great.
But I think a lot
people just aren't
aware of the constant sort
of drip feed of negativity
that's out there.
I think, I hate to say,
but a lot of people
live in sort of heterosexual,
cisgender bubble.
And while they're
sort of tangentially
aware of these issues happening,
because it's not affecting them
directly, they're not aware
of how hurtful it can be
and how difficult it
can be for trans people.
And I constantly say this.
Look, if you have a
friend who is trans,
if you have somebody in
your life who's trans,
reach out and just
say, how are you doing?
Is everything OK?
There's some shitty
stuff in the news.
Are you OK?
Are you feeling all right?
Do you want to talk
about anything?
Do you just want to go for
a coffee and have a natter?
So I think it's
just important just
to be there, be supportive,
and just reach out when you can
say, just let's go for coffee.
JULIEN FINLAY:
That's a good one.
That's valuable for
anyone, I would say, not
depending on their--
AOIFE MARTIN: Oops.
JULIEN FINLAY: You're good.
It won't fall there--
to anyone, depending on
their identification.
But specifically
to some minorities,
I think we would have to develop
a stronger sense of empathy,
as in, oh, I'm aware Aoife may
not feel good today for X, Y,
Z reasons, or Finlay either.
You both mentioned
that education and also
the idea of a rebel
club, that where
you could have seen the
internet for a while,
like where the minorities
would live or develop or hide.
Do you think that's
still the case?
Do you think the
internet is still
a safe haven for minorities?
FINLAY WILSON: It's tricky.
Because I see a lot of people
who give the guise of support
online-- so for example,
if somebody sends me hate,
like it's almost becoming
one of my favorite things,
is just to publicly shame them.
When that happens, it's always
the people in the rainbow
bubble that tell me to
not post that stuff,
to actually stay quiet.
Because they have an
institutionalized oppression
where they're like,
no, no, no, no, no.
Don't talk about this.
And that's from people who
it's also happening to.
And it's a very strange,
like, oh, they've got us good.
They've really got us
good, so to actually
be able to speak to people
who will then actually
stand up and also be
happy to speak out
about that kind of thing.
I would say that's
much rarer to find
that than to find the people
that will become apologists,
that will just say, no, no,
no, just don't think about it.
Don't talk about it.
Certainly don't share it.
Certainly don't have
an opinion about it.
Makes me sick.
JULIEN FINLAY: But
you still share?
FINLAY WILSON: Of course.
JULIEN FINLAY: Both of you,
have you ever posted something,
and then you regretted
it and deleted,
or have had double thoughts,
either because you thought
you'd be hateful
or because you felt
that was not your job to do?
AOIFE MARTIN: Well, you
should see my drafts folder
in Twitter, stuff I've
wanted to say but not said.
And if ever I die, I'm hoping
one of my friends will log
in and just delete
everything in there,
stuff you wouldn't-- generally,
I'm quite careful because I
know how it can affect
people because I've been
on the receiving end.
I'm quite aware of what I say.
I don't always--
sometimes, I do lash out.
Sometimes I do say
something I regret later
or something I
shouldn't have said.
I'm also aware that
I have a platform
and that there are younger
trans people possibly reading
what I write.
And I once wrote a
pretty negative article
about being trans, because
I was going through sort
of major dysphoria at the time.
And it was sort of like why it
sucks being trans, basically.
And the article was published.
But I actually had to email
the editor and say, look,
could you just change
the headline on that just
to make it sound less negative?
I mean, he didn't change the
content of the article, which
was fine, because that's how
I was feeling at the time.
But rather than
calling the article,
it sucks being trans, let's be
a bit more positive about it
and have something, rather than
having that negativity there.
Because I do try to,
as much as I can,
highlight the positive aspects
and just to usualize this
and to say, look, it
is OK to be trans.
There's nothing to be
ashamed about, you know?
JULIEN FINLAY: Finlay,
do you regret your posts?
FINLAY WILSON: Well, some
images that I've put up-- well,
there was one time.
[LAUGHTER]
I'd done this photo shoot
with my twin brother.
And it was great.
It was lovely.
And I thought, I'm just
going to chuck, like,
70 images on Facebook.
And then I was
like, this one image
has been shared 500 times.
It's cause you can
see everything.
I didn't know.
I had no clue.
I regret that.
But as for my responses
online, not so much-- but
I have shifted my
tactics for the people
who leave hateful comments on
my Instagram in particular.
Because I know there's--
for example, I teach a group
of kids with additional support
needs, like multiple
disabilities.
And I know actually
daily, they check
in to my Facebook to
see what poses I'm doing
and then see if
they can recreate it
in their classroom,
every single day.
And so if they're seeing me
being really nasty to somebody
who's been really
nasty to me, it's
not setting a very good example.
So one of my new
favorites, it's like,
oops, you're on the wrong
page, fingernail emoji.
And then you
usually would direct
the followers to be like, go
and send them a message for me.
And I send in the troops.
So I will leave them a little
bit like, whoops-a-daisy.
And then the troops go
in there and will usually
do the critique work
for me without--
it's not saying that I
won't go in and do the work.
But it's me saying, I'm not
going to engage with you.
But also, you're on my page.
You must like what you see.
[LAUGHTER]
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
There is an argument.
I mean, I've had
this sort of argue
with people, where
they say, just
don't give them any limelight.
And I agree.
I mean, it's easy for people
to say that because they're not
the ones being attacked.
FINLAY WILSON: Yeah.
AOIFE MARTIN: And
sometimes, I will ignore.
And I will just not
pass any remarks.
Or I will I will do what you do.
I will send in the troops.
I will quote, tweet this.
Look what this arsehole is out
there saying, sort of thing,
and just let everybody
else do the hard work.
But I'm also aware that
since I came out at work,
a lot of people from
MasterCard follow me.
So I've become much
less wary on my Twitter.
I'm much more, a little bit--
I hold myself back a
little bit, I think.
I probably shouldn't.
But I'm much more self-conscious
than I used to be, I have say.
JULIEN FINLAY: Being
self-conscious offline,
we will open the floor.
So prepare questions.
But I have 1,000 more
if you're OK with that.
Feel free just raising your
hand if you have any questions.
And we'll find a mic.
You're talking about tactics.
You're talking about
sending the troops.
That's like warfare.
Is that your day-to-day
situation, you're fighting
negativity?
FINLAY WILSON: It is day to day.
Even today, when I was sitting
on the plane, somebody left a--
it was, as insults
go, pretty tame.
They are just like, your
bum doesn't look good.
And I was like, hm, OK.
Sure.
72 million people disagree.
And I just wrote back.
And I was just like-- again,
I was just like, whoops.
I think you think I
appreciate what you think.
I don't.
And then they wrote back, like,
no, it's really that left one.
And it was so specific, I
just found it more amusing.
I was like, I'm not feeling
too self-conscious right now,
even though it's the
one facing everybody.
But it's relentless.
There's lots of these little
comments that chip in.
And actually to have a tactic,
sometimes just going in
has been like, oh, oh.
Give them a little something.
But for the really
negative ones,
I've had a lot of really
terrible experiences
where the fans have gone in.
And they have reported
it and then have
tried to go through the
reporting channels on Instagram
primarily.
And then they
report back and say,
Instagram said they're
not going to do anything.
Instagram said that even though
there's hate speech there,
they won't do anything about it.
So the safeguards
that my troops use
will only work occasionally.
And that's frustrating.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah, I
think that's a big problem
in social media.
I primarily used Twitter as
my social media platform.
And you report stuff on there.
And they say, oh, there's
nothing to see here.
Everything's fine.
Or this does not
violate our rules.
And you're [INAUDIBLE] well,
clearly it bloody well does,
you know?
And I was getting harassment
from one particular person.
And it was constant.
And this person talked about
me, talked about my family,
talked about my kids, et cetera,
and said some really, really
negative stuff about me.
And I reported it to Twitter.
And they said, no, it
doesn't violate our rules.
And eventually, I got
talking to somebody
who knew somebody in Twitter.
And I sent her a load of tweets
that this person had sent.
And next thing I know,
this person was banned.
But since then, this person
has set up another account
and is now on her fifth account
and is still harassing me.
So it's a very, very difficult
thing to police on social media
and enforce anything.
JULIEN FINLAY: Yeah.
And that's why I wanted us
to lead to, as a new report,
but nothing is happening,
or not fast enough.
We discussed that
earlier and how--
in the green room,
when everything happens
and you are not there--
and there's a code of conduct
that was launched by the EU.
But it's not legally binding.
It's an agreement.
Do you want to
control the internet?
Or do you want to have
the internet controlled?
Do you want to let
loose, everyone?
And what do you
think about that?
I'm sure you've all
reported, as you said.
But then most of
the time, nothing
is happening in your favor.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah, I think it's
a difficult thing to police.
And I think governments would
love to control the internet.
And governments would love
to control social media.
Because the government doesn't
like us talking to each other
and advocating together
and protesting together.
I mean, it's social
media that brought
the grassroots campaigns
for abortion in this country
and for marriage equality like,
the Home to Vote campaign,
all social media led,
all grassroots led.
And the government wasn't
ever going to do anything.
So they would love to
control us, I think.
So I think, yeah, you have
to take the good with the bad
as well, I think.
You know, it would
be nice if we were
a bit politer to each
other on social media
and on the internet.
But I don't see that happening.
JULIEN FINLAY: Do
you see it happening
on yourself, whenever
you have reporting, even
with the police, physical?
FINLAY WILSON: Well,
that's the thing.
It goes much wider as
a problem for society
than just policing the internet.
I mean, even the police
themselves were not
following through on
their basic function.
So that was something
outside of that.
So last week in Scotland,
Scotland said that as part
of the curriculum for primary
schools and secondary schools,
they would be introducing
LGBTQ+ education.
And this was a huge thing.
And everybody is like,
woo, this is great.
And the main sticking
point-- and we
were speaking about this,
in the green room, again.
If only you'd been in the green
room, everything happened.
The main thing that everybody
was rallying against,
as you were saying,
that trans rights
are 20 years behind gay
rights, is everybody's beef
was with trans.
And they were using
the same rhetoric
that was used about gay
people 20 years ago.
20 years ago, it
would've been, you're
trying to turn my kid gay.
It's like, no-- born that way.
Now you're starting to get it.
But they're not
there yet with trans.
But education has gotten
people to a certain point.
But there's a lot
more education to do.
So I don't know if
policing is going to do it.
But getting people
who are more educated,
people who are actually
questioning, and as you said,
sort of normalizing the
situation, usualizing it.
As that happens,
we can only hope
that that will not be there.
Because we also rely on
our freedom of speech
to be able to fight back.
We can't fight back against
it if we're being silenced
and if we're all being policed.
JULIEN FINLAY: Yeah, and
this idea of being policed
is rising.
I know like on Monday,
if I'm correct,
Emmanuel Macron,
French president,
did launch this agreement.
And three main
countries have not
agreed, thus being
China, US, and Russia,
which would be major
impacts on the internet.
And if we could go to--
well, yeah.
So that's a quote from a Jewish
sociologist, who does say
basically, tech companies
are seeing themselves
as publishers.
So now we are responsible.
The companies will be
responsible for the content
online.
Who's at fault, the
messenger or the medium?
Who should be policed?
Who should be responsible for
the tribune that is published?
Is it the journal?
Is it the reader?
Is it the writer?
What are your thoughts?
AOIFE MARTIN: I think the
medium has probably more
responsibility in this area.
Certainly, I know, again,
speaking about Twitter,
they're quite happy to have--
if somebody has a
lot of followers.
Remember Milo on Twitter?
They were happy to go along
with his stuff for ages,
all the hateful rhetoric
that he was espousing.
They still haven't banned
Donald Trump for god's sake
and the stuff he comes out with.
It's because--
JULIEN FINLAY: He was
banned for one hour.
FINLAY WILSON: One day.
AOIFE MARTIN: Was he?
Oh yeah, that's right,
it was accidental.
But they're quite happy to allow
these people their platform
because it generates
more news from Twitter.
It generates
notoriety for Twitter.
It generates more income and
advertisement for Twitter,
you know?
And if you look at any online
publication, any newspaper
publication, all the
comments beneath the articles
themselves, a lot of
it's quite negative.
And it's quite right wing.
But they're happy
to go with this,
because it generates clicks.
It generates people
looking at their content.
And it generates
advertising revenue.
JULIEN FINLAY: I'll go
back with you on this.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
JULIEN FINLAY: And then
we have a question.
So if you could just tell us
your name and your question,
please?
AUDIENCE: So my
name is Roseanne.
My question relates a bit to
the situation in Scotland.
Because when you were
talking at the beginning,
I also remember that
they're introducing it
into the schools'
curriculum, which
seems to be the best idea
to educate people early on.
But then there seems to
be this huge discrepancy
between that idea and
very public, I think,
court proceedings against what
is perceived as hate speech
online.
I think there was a comedian.
He was convicted
for a piece that he
made that Jewish people
might feel is distasteful.
And at the same time,
you say whatever
you reported that
happened to an actual life
outside of any online
interactions, people damaging
the tires of the
car, threatening you
with physical
violence, threatening
to kill your animal,
nothing was done
as far as I understood you.
So what would be the best
approach to actually tackle
that real-life problem?
FINLAY WILSON: I think
one challenge would
be perhaps for the police
and the authorities
to perhaps look at
the fact that there
are obvious inequalities in how
crime reporting, but also crime
handling, is dealt with.
So certainly when it came to
me handing over this letter,
I was told, oh, we'll
take your fingerprints.
We'll do it right now.
They didn't.
Then they said, well, come back.
We'll take your fingerprints.
They still didn't.
They said they would
interview my neighbors
to find out who it was.
They didn't.
Then it became a
high-profile case
because I took it to the BBC.
And they still didn't.
So the ball was dropped
on many opportunities.
So that's not uncommon
in that constituency.
They say that their budget is
so stretched that they cannot
investigate hate crime.
So if we are encouraging people
to report more hate crime
or to be more aware of it,
and for especially people who
it's happening to, too feel
confident in reporting it,
they need a bigger budget to
be able to investigate it.
Because all the other
stuff is still happening.
They're stretched thin.
So I can understand
that they may not
have the resources to follow
through with a lot of it.
So there is that, more
resources for them to do that.
But then it's like, OK,
bigger police presence.
Do we want that either?
Have they always been allies?
Can they be allies?
It's a tricky situation.
But if it comes down to
education, the person who
wrote the letter, everyone who
I showed the letter to, said,
this is an older
person's handwriting.
I was like, are these views
that are going to disappear?
Or are they views that
are still current that
are still being passed on
generation to generation?
This is where I hope
the education part will
have children identifying
with people in the playground,
rather than-- it almost
seems like, certainly
when I was at school, it only
after school that I was like,
oh, my god.
There's gay people.
Oh, my god.
And then I look back.
And it's like, actually,
most of you were.
But we didn't know.
And we can identify them.
So actually, to
have the education
that school is really important.
I had to sit through,
in my high school,
an assembly with
the whole of my year
gathered, where we were told
by a priest at the front
that it was Adam and
Eve, not Adam and Steve.
And they battered that into us.
So if school is going
to move more inclusion,
I look forward to seeing
how those children will
go into the world.
I see the young creators,
the young YouTubers,
putting out a very diverse
message, a very almost
sometimes gender fluid message.
And see, that is so wonderful
to see, to see that.
But that's a great thing.
But we still need to focus on
there are people who really
get left out and struggle.
For example, somebody
who I teach yoga to,
we picked her back up
after her parents sent her
to gay conversion therapy.
And so she had
needles in her fingers
to try and beat the gay away.
This still happens in Scotland.
It can still happen in Scotland.
So I would love if they
legislated that more and then
included that in the education.
This is how we used
to deal with this,
like acknowledging some
of the painful history.
I think that's been a big thing
in a lot of minority movements
is you need to acknowledge some
of the wrong that's been done.
Because if you don't,
how do we move forwards?
This is where LGBT History
Months are actually
really important
aspects as education.
And I think that will be
great to see that in schools.
JULIEN FINLAY: Aoife,
what are your thoughts
on the next generation
of creators online?
AOIFE MARTIN: I'm very,
very hopeful, actually.
I grew up in the '70s and '80s,
when there was no internet
and there was no [INAUDIBLE].
There was none of this.
And looking at
young people today,
and they're much more outgoing.
They're much more
accepting of who they are.
accepting of diversity.
I mean, kids aren't
born bigoted, you know?
They get bigotry
from other people.
They get it from society.
They get it from the media,
from what they see around them.
And to see young kids
coming out and young kids
being themselves,
it's just wonderful,
and long may it last.
JULIEN FINLAY: All right.
I have a question.
But I think I'd love
to hear your thoughts.
And I'd love to hear how you
experience internet, what you
think of the EU regulations.
Because I have tackled
this a bit briefly.
But we can go back again.
So go ahead, whoever
wants to take the mic--
so name and question, please.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yeah.
Hi.
My name name's Kelsey.
Before I just say my question,
Finlay, I have your book.
I really appreciate the
pictures at the end.
[LAUGHTER]
FINLAY WILSON: Don't
give away the ending.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Really, as someone
who does create content,
I wanted to ask if some of these
hateful messages that you're
getting constantly
on this content
is making you either
sort of second guess
putting the content out
there, or even maybe
revising what you're creating
because of your getting
this negative images and
messaging constantly?
Does that change how
you think about putting
your content out there or the
things that you're producing?
FINLAY WILSON: I wish
it didn't, but it does.
So for example, I
was putting out--
sometimes if I put up a
photo of my partner and I,
sometimes I really do
question, like, OK.
Why am I putting this out here?
And sometimes I want it to
be just a simple sharing.
But then it really easily
becomes politicized.
Really easily, it becomes almost
like an aggressive sharing
in retaliation to something
else that has happened.
And so it does start to seep
into the posts in some way.
But then sometimes, I might
then shift it and actually write
that.
So the image can speak.
But the text can also speak.
So I had a lot of
real body shaming.
That was about three
or four days ago.
So then I posted one.
And I just wrote like
a letter to myself
from me now to when I
really hated my body.
And I wrote that.
And a lot of people
resonated with that.
But it was reactionary.
But it also allowed me a
moment of self reflection.
So it's frustrating in
that it does give me
grounds to create material
that is reactionary.
And it does put a
voice out there.
But it is sometimes
tainted by the fact
that it's come in from
such a negative source.
So it does.
And it does make
me second guess.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JULIEN FINLAY: I'll
go to you, Antonio.
But that's what you did as well.
And I've read that on
[INAUDIBLE] blog, like a letter
to your young self.
Could you tell us
a bit more of this?
And also, maybe I'm
wrong, but I know
if you're within a smaller
community than the mainstream
world, maybe going
online could be a refuge.
So your younger self, would they
go online to have a safe haven?
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah, I think so.
I mean, like for now, I wrote
a letter to my younger self.
And basically, other
than buy shares in Apple,
I told myself that
it was OK to be trans
and that you will
get through this.
I think when you're
that young and you
know you're different
from everybody else,
and you feel different
to everybody else,
and there is no
representation out there,
and you don't know anybody
else either in your peer group
or on television or
anyone who is trans,
and you never see
yourself represented,
you think you're
the only person,
and so just that, it was
just to myself, saying look,
you will get there.
You will come through this.
And you will
eventually be happy.
You will be an out trans woman.
And you will speak about your
experiences of being trans.
And I think if I'd had the
internet in those days,
then I think, yeah,
I probably would have
come out a lot sooner, I think.
And I know in the
early days of internet,
there was a lot of stuff
out there which we probably
shouldn't be viewing
at that age, you know?
And certainly, I think it
was difficult initially.
Even when I first started
using the internet,
there were very few
communities out there.
I think social media
has improved enormously.
And yeah, I
definitely would have
be online and definitely
would have probably
come out a lot sooner, yeah.
JULIEN FINLAY: All right.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Antonio.
My question is more for Finlay.
You kind of mentioned
that in your video,
the men-to-men action
started or contributed
to the hate or the backlash.
I don't know if you know the
Kilted Coaches or the Coaches
Kilted from Scotland.
FINLAY WILSON: Yeah.
They live down the road.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I wanted
to know if you know
or if you know the story, if
something happened to them,
they had the same backlash.
I don't think they
identify themselves as gay.
But they have a lot of
men-to-men action in a kilt.
FINLAY WILSON:
They have actually
spoken really publicly about--
if you are watching, guys,
we've spoken about this.
So actually, we
spoke about it live.
And they have addressed it
to their fans quite a lot.
But obviously,
they're both straight.
They have their wives.
They've got their kids.
They're very open about that.
But they're also
happy to play to--
what do we call it,
like the Pink Pound--
to work that.
But when I did it, people
were uncomfortable,
because they knew.
By that point, I'd already
produced-- the hate
letter had already come in.
I'd already produced the video.
I mean, like, this
is terrible, blah.
I'd already being seen as that.
And so video number two,
the people are like, maybe
these are straight guys.
Maybe we'll find straight
guys in the woods.
Suddenly, it was like, no,
it's a faggot in the woods.
And that was a huge
shift to see that.
They knew.
And they were uncomfortable.
And it was a really
big change to see that.
And the languaging really
changed in that regard.
Yeah.
And that's from that
piece of information.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Rina.
And I have a question.
If you ever talk to
the haters and ask,
what actually are you afraid of?
FINLAY WILSON: This is
almost a misunderstanding
that homophobia means
that they're scared.
They're not usually
scared of us at all.
I think everybody in this
room has had conversations
with people where you
have had disagreements.
And you're never going
to meet eye to eye.
I've never had one of
those celebrity turnaround
moments, where when you've
like spoken to a hater,
and they've been
like, oh, actually
I'm just really hurting.
And let me tell you this thing.
That doesn't happen
to me, all right?
That hasn't happen to me.
They just spew their venom.
And at some point,
I have to say,
I cannot attend
this arena anymore.
I'm done here.
I gave you a moment.
I tried.
But I can't.
I've never had one of those
breakthrough moments, where
it's like, we're going
to have a crowdfunder
campaign for their surgery.
I've not had that
at all, you know?
You know kind of the one I mean?
Like was it Sarah Silverman
did that against her hater?
And it was lovely, lovely thing.
That's a very romanticized thing
about online hate, I think.
JULIEN FINLAY: Would that
be the same for you, Aoife,
like you would not--
I don't know.
The potential of hate
would prevent you
of engaging online with
your haters or your least
appreciated fans?
AOIFE MARTIN: So somewhat
similar to Finlay,
I think I'm generally-- when
I first started coming out
and was quite outspoken about
being trans, I was very open
and would answer
people's questions.
You know, because you want
to sort of educate people.
FINLAY WILSON:
Yeah, information.
AOIFE MARTIN: It's information.
But the older I get, the
more cynical I get about it.
And I think I'm very quick
now at spotting when somebody
is being genuine and
somebody is just asking,
trying to catch me
out on something
and use it against me.
And I'm very, very quick
to sort of just block
people on Twitter.
My life is not a debate.
You can't sit there and demand
why I should get rights.
I should have the rights.
That's the basic
bottom line here.
FINLAY WILSON: Exactly.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
And so I just don't
engage with it anymore.
Because like you say, you
cannot change their minds.
There is no wonderful
moment where
people go, oh, you're right.
And I'm going to change my ways.
It doesn't happen.
FINLAY WILSON: I
think a lot of people
also think that trolls are
looking for engagement,
that not necessarily.
I mean, when I did the
video about mental health,
one of the first
five comments was,
you should have followed
through on killing yourself.
What do you do with that?
What do you do with
how you interact
with that person who's, in a
sentence, wished death on you?
AOIFE MARTIN: That's the thing.
I mean, 48% of young trans
kids have attempted suicide.
And when this stat is
ever sort of produced
and when I've mentioned
this online, people say,
well, they're obviously
not trying hard enough.
I mean, how do you deal
with that sort of hate?
You just don't.
You just go, sorry.
JULIEN FINLAY: 48%?
AOIFE MARTIN: Sorry?
JULIEN FINLAY: 48%, you said?
AOIFE MARTIN: 48%, yes, so
you just don't deal with.
You cannot engage
with these people.
There's just no point, you know?
FINLAY WILSON: Yeah, like
the LGBT suicide rate
is high, very high, much
higher in trans communities.
And to see people writing
and wishing death on you
is damaging.
You can't help but question
not only their actions,
but you begin to
question yourself.
And remember, we were saying
earlier about that time
to reflect.
If somebody is questioning
your existence,
has the troll had that?
Has the troll genuinely
sat there and then
reflected themselves on what
they have written and said,
should I die?
No, of course they haven't.
But they will do it to us.
JULIEN FINLAY: And
that's why it's sneaky.
Because you would only see
the hate or the comments
or the meme as something
online, not something
that, well, boomerangs
physically in your face--
to use another boomerang thing.
But online hate does kill.
You have young people
taking off their lives.
You have people hiding
themselves, like you say,
in house.
And there's a lack of education.
There's a lack of prevention.
There's a lack of repression.
But there's also beautiful
things, as you mentioned.
There's also
creating a community.
And there's also initiatives,
like an app called ReThink
that I shared with you.
So that app, which you
can download online--
it's called ReThink-- it scans
your words that you're typing.
And it allows you to post before
posting, basically telling you,
hm.
Are you sure you
want to do that now?
And 93% of the 50,000
users have decided
not to post the
message they were
writing in the first place.
To what extent do you think
technology can educate them,
educate those haters?
Or is it just a battle
we will never fight?
It will have been black
people in the past.
It will have been gays.
And it is trans.
It will be something
else I'm against.
I have a lot of hate.
But what do you feel about that?
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
I mean, see, I think when
people write hateful stuff,
they're not seeing the person
on the other side of the screen.
So there is no sort of concept
of a human being there.
And so it's easy to write stuff.
It's easy to write stuff
that you wouldn't say face
to face to somebody.
And I would never tweet
in anger or would never
write an email in
anger, because you
know you're going to
regret it the next day.
FINLAY WILSON: You a
better person than me.
[LAUGHS]
AOIFE MARTIN: You just know
you're going to regret someday.
And I think that having an
app that sort of captures
that, I don't know
if it works or not.
I mean, I would
hope people would
have enough
self-perception to realize
to know what they're doing.
But obviously, that
isn't the case.
JULIEN FINLAY: Finlay, before
I conclude and really open
the conversation
and before you tell
us more about your full hatred
emails that you regret--
FINLAY WILSON: It mostly
involved my ex-husband.
But that's a different thing.
JULIEN FINLAY: Oh, juicy.
Same topic-- would you be aware?
Or would you know any ways
technology can somehow--
FINLAY WILSON: I find
that interesting.
Obviously, the user would
have to consent to its use.
This is the thing about
policing the internet.
We can't have that
going out for everybody.
But to give people
that moment of pause,
where the perhaps
taught hateful impulse
is the first thing
that is there.
Maybe that small pause is
enough of a window for empathy
to come in.
But empathy is that big part.
You almost cannot exist now
and not know somebody-- well,
maybe--
not know somebody
that is gay, trans.
You will know someone.
There will be someone
in your family
that you can look at and
acknowledge their humanity, so
much so, to the point that when
we teach our yoga teachers,
it's like, OK.
You need to remember you're
working with humans, not just
machines and make
them do X, Y, and Z.
So we make them sit and look
each other, uninterrupted,
in their eyes for like minutes.
It's really uncomfortable.
But they usually end up seeing
mirrored what they are seeing.
So they will soften.
And so even though
they may have had
some animosity
towards that person,
they will see a kinship.
They can't get
that from a screen.
They see something.
There might be some
other insidious thing,
like a jealousy.
There might be a bitterness.
There might be some other
story that comes in.
And they forget that
the other person
has just as unique and valid
a story as anybody else.
And the screen is the barrier.
In person, it's
very unusual for me
to have somebody spout
venom to my face.
It's more it will always be
hating behind the screen.
JULIEN FINLAY: Let's have
all your questions heard.
Oh, thanks, [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
FINLAY WILSON: You
have to do the work.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Is this on?
This is on.
Thank you so much for
talking so openly.
I wanted to ask about--
you spoke a little about how
harassment online and hate
online will lead you to police
or regulate your online posts
and self-expression online.
You spoke a little about
how you set your self
doubt even before you
step out the door, even.
I guess I just wanted to
ask more broadly about how
being online in general and
being influential online
has maybe caused you to regulate
or police or expression.
You mentioned a little
bit earlier about
how there's a studio you're
aware of who replicate
your poses on a frequent basis.
And so you're
mindful of how they
might perceive you responding
negatively to online hate.
And so I wonder in general how--
not cyberbullying, but
I guess cyber-validation
or cyber-fandom has
maybe caused you
to regulate or police or alter
your online self-expression,
or even offline?
JULIEN FINLAY: Aoife, do
you want to take that first?
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
So I don't think it's affected
me too much in that sense.
I'm quite outspoken
about what I talk about.
about, obviously,
about trans rights
is probably primarily
what I talk about online.
And I'm sure people
are going, oh, god.
There she goes again,
off on one of her rants
in one of her threads.
And so I'm more sort of
self-conscious sometimes
about it.
I'm going, oh, do
people actually
want to listen to this again?
Do people want to hear
this sort of stuff again?
Because I know I
tweet about it a lot.
And I talk about it a lot.
And I'm going, are
people going to think
I'm being a little
bit narcissistic
about this and with that?
So I think that's more of how
I sort of regulate myself.
I don't do as many long posts
or threads as I used to do.
Because I think I have the
same bunch of followers.
And they're obviously
aware of my politics
and aware of where
I'm coming from
and aware of what I talk about.
And so yeah, I think it's
more I'm much more self-aware
than I used to be.
I'm much more afraid that
I'm actually boring people
with my stuff now, you know?
So generally, I hold back
a little because of that.
But I had a thread
this week, because it's
Trans Awareness Week.
And sometimes if the muse
just strikes, I'll just go.
And I'll write away.
And I'll just post what
I'm thinking, so post first
and then regret later
sort of thing, you know?
FINLAY WILSON: I mean,
certainly for me,
Instagram is my main platform.
It's been where it's
always been a journal
of my practice, my yoga practice
and kind of what's going on,
day to day.
So that part continues.
I use it to catalog some of
the work breakthroughs I have.
But those things
that happen there,
they don't make it into
my classroom environment.
I'm just more aware--
that example of there's
a class that looks at it.
They are probably
looking at the poses,
because they are six,
six or seven years old.
So they're unlikely to
be reading the politics
or me rambling on at somebody.
But it still is a thought
that they are looking at it.
But I still stand by and have
always stood by, in person,
if I see somebody going after me
or going after somebody that I
care about, I'm going
to speak up about it.
If that's happening,
I'll speak up about it.
Even when I was
at high school, I
set up this anti-bullying
network in my school.
So that bit has been there.
As for the online, the
online stuff for me,
that's not fabricated.
That's my every day.
That's why the floor looks dirty
and the windows aren't clean.
Yesterday, I
accidentally showed you
a video of the toilet
because I forgot
to shut the bathroom door.
So I like to think
that I'm being
as transparent as possible.
And even though some of
my posts are generated
in a reactionary way,
it's still my genuine take
on the situation.
So I'm still able
to, even though--
has it become a
validation anymore?
I think it's more like I
feel more appreciated when
the voice feels heard,
and especially when
I hear the rally cry go
out, when people are like,
this has happened to me as well.
And that's powerful.
Because the young
me didn't have that.
The young me was so
isolated, even when
I was starting to
come out, there
were events and things happening
there that were so destructive.
There were things that happened
when I was way young that
were so destructive.
Actually, I've even tried to
speak to my partner about it
face-to-face.
He said, I can never understand
what you went through.
And that's it.
And even though he may not
mean to put a wall there,
there's a solid wall there.
So for example, you speak to
someone about child abuse.
And their hackles are up.
But if I write about that,
it's like a pebble in a pond.
And the ripples will reach out.
And some of the other people
that have been affected by that
will actually gather together
and feel heartened by it.
And actually, I
feel like that's--
I would never think putting
a sexual abuse story online
is looking for validation.
But it is looking for an outlet
to put the emotion to paper,
usually for the first time.
So usually when I'm
writing, I'm not
writing there on my
computer, or being like,
let's see how long--
let's edit this.
It's just coming out of my head.
And very rarely do
I edit unless I've
had like an absolute
autocorrect error.
But it's as direct
as I can make it.
Some of it may be reactionary.
But I'm not policing it too
much, if that makes sense.
I'm trying to be as
genuine as possible.
And I try to dumb it down.
Because my yoga classes, I am--
well, it's a show.
Let's put it that way.
It's a show.
JULIEN FINLAY: All right.
We're all going at 4:00 PM.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah, I think
that's a very good point.
I mean, there are
some subjects I'm
uncomfortable talking about.
Because I don't know
how to express myself.
And it's certainly
around gender dysphoria,
but the feelings of
dysphoria and what it's like.
Because it's very
hard to explain that
to somebody who isn't trans.
And I do write bits and pieces
about it when I can or when--
and it does, as you said,
those ripples, they go out.
People see it.
People who are going
through the same thing
will take some sort of
validation from that.
And they go, well, I'm not the
only one who feels like that.
And it's nice to get that.
And when I see people
writing about dysphoria,
well, yeah, I see that
describes perfectly how I feel.
You get it.
Whereas, a lot of people
just don't understand it.
And it's very hard for somebody
who hasn't experienced it
to understand what it's like.
FINLAY WILSON: I think
that was the power
behind the Me Too movement.
There are lots of
those movements that
happened that didn't
get as much traction
as the Me Too movement.
But on the back of
that, actually, there
were a lot of men, for example,
that also used the same tag
and said, actually,
it's us as well.
It's all of us.
And so sometimes,
these social movements
can be so positive, so powerful.
But it does take
people to do it,
to have that unaltered voice.
Yeah.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah, just
to know you're not alone--
that's the main thing.
You know you're not
the only person who
have experienced this.
You are not on your own.
FINLAY WILSON: Yeah.
JULIEN FINLAY: We
have two questions
posted online internally.
So it's policed and controlled.
But then we can have more
questions from you all.
FINLAY WILSON: Hopefully,
they took a minute
to reflect on what they wrote.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIEN FINLAY: There's
one [INAUDIBLE]..
The first one I have is--
will be for both of you.
So body positivity is
impacted by negativity
from those around you.
Like bullying, those
with weight issues
are excluded and
treated, assumed lazy.
Those who experience
this feel isolated
and driving depression.
How can, at Google--
but I would say,
how can any tech companies--
can we be truly inclusive?
And can we see everyone
as a worthy person?
That's a very good question.
AOIFE MARTIN: That's
a great question.
And I'm not sure
I can answer it.
Body positivity, yeah,
that's a huge thing for me.
It's something I
struggle with myself.
And I, yeah, I'm a
middle-aged, fat, trans woman.
And the word fat is something I
find it very difficult to say.
I find it very
difficult to actually--
that was probably the first
time I've used this publicly,
to say that word, the
F word, as I call it.
And yeah, it's something
I struggle with.
I hate photographs of myself.
I hate seeing pictures
of myself online.
I do it because I'm trying
to be more positive about,
this is me.
This is what I look like.
Accept it or walk away.
But I still find it
very, very difficult.
I've done a couple
of portrait sessions
for some trans projects
that I'm involved in.
And again, I'm
doing it because I'm
trying to be more open about
who I am and be more positive
and be more body positive.
But I still find it
very, very difficult.
And it's something I find very,
very difficult to talk about.
And someday, I
probably will, I'll
write a lot about
this when I get there.
And I think it's
only by sort of--
again, it's representation.
It's showing different bodies,
different people, people
of different color, gender,
sexualities, body shapes,
body types.
We are inundated with
images all the time
of thin, white, blonde
people generally.
And we need to get away
from that sort of thing.
People's bodies are--
everybody's different.
Not everybody is thin.
Not everybody is tall.
Not everybody is
white or blonde.
So we need to--
I think, yeah, we should
be promoting that.
JULIEN FINLAY: Yeah.
And we all have F words,
I guess, as demons.
But thank you for saying this.
And I'm sorry I asked
you for the picture now.
I feel like--
AOIFE MARTIN: Oh, no, no.
That's actually-- that was done
in a photo booth at MasterCard.
And that one's fine, because
it's only from chest up,
which is grand.
JULIEN FINLAY: Finlay,
I know body positivity
is one of your main, well,
energy that is driving you.
Tell us more.
FINLAY WILSON: For me,
I don't necessarily
see that as something that
someone else has responsibility
for.
When I have people coming
in, and they're coming in,
and they have this
negative self-image,
then my drive is to get
them to do the work.
And that's the
work of acceptance.
So part of yoga is
this shift of being
more conscious about your
actions, how you move,
but also practicing
acceptance of what is going on
or what your current reality
is and what your powers are
to change and affect things.
So that process and
one of journaling
and of introspection,
that begins
the work of beginning to
care for the organism.
And if you are willing to
do the work of the care,
it doesn't matter how it looks.
It doesn't matter
how the post looks.
I work with people with
multiple disabilities.
They're not looking on
the Instagram channels
and being like, well,
I can't do that.
They are interested in
creating a shape that
will work for them.
And they feel something
and feel steady in it.
So yoga is great in this
adaptable way of teaching
people the skills
to begin to practice
acceptance of themselves.
I and I think that's
where it needs to start.
If it doesn't start
from there, then
it is that external validation
from another to say,
I need you to be OK with me.
No.
You need to be OK with you.
If you're not OK
with you, then this
is where it's all
going to go wrong.
And this is where
the haters come in.
And they make that
process harder.
But on a daily basis, it
can be incredibly helpful.
Now this is where
I'm going to get
killed by the yoga community,
because not all yoga is created
equal.
My first yoga teacher
drove me to bulimia.
Because she said,
you look this way.
You've got this fat back here.
I had like a 38-inch waist,
which I don't have now.
And she was like, this bit
here, that pose, this twist,
is not going to work.
Let me teach you this ancient
cleansing technique, which
was basically sticking your
finger down your throat
and vomiting in a bucket, so
that I could lose the weight.
And, oh, I lost the weight.
I lost a lot of weight.
I lost all my self-respect.
I then started torturing
myself with food.
Then I kind of
got into cleanses,
where I would say,
oh, I'm detoxing,
which basically was code for
I'm just drinking water today
because I don't deserve to eat.
And it really actually drove
me into this very dark place.
And then actually,
the style of yoga
that I teach now, the first
class of that that I went to,
it was the very first moment.
And I had already been teaching
yoga for about three years.
I was still struggling
with an eating disorder.
I was so part bulimic but was
also skipping meals and making
it a health choice,
was skipping meals,
was not in great
shape health-wise.
And I went onto to this class.
It was the first time
ever in a yoga class
that an instructor had
asked me to feel how I felt.
And it was just like,
take a deep breath.
Feel somewhere in your body that
is sore and needs attention.
I had never done that before.
I was like, what
the fuck is this?
Who is this hippy?
And--
JULIEN FINLAY: Says the guy
wearing a kilt with a beard.
FINLAY WILSON: Do not
call me a hipster, sir,
despite all of this.
So by the end of that class--
it was a two-hour class--
by the end of that class,
I was sitting there,
shell-shocked.
Because I had invested a
lot of my energy and stuff
in my career.
And I was like, I'm
a good yoga teacher.
I am totally at top of my game.
And after that class,
I felt that everything
I had learned-- this is after
one class-- everything was
a deception and that I had
to face up to in that moment
that I had been damaging
myself and calling it healing.
And that was a real gear shift.
And so that was
when I started doing
the work of introspection.
Because the work I'd been doing
before had been a distraction,
which isn't the same.
So I was doing the yoga.
I was doing the
physical exercises.
But I was using it
to punish my body.
I wasn't using it to heal it.
And it was only when
I made that shift
and I really changed
styles of yoga
that I was actually able
to really feel for that.
And that was powerful.
I did this process.
It's called the shamanic death--
very dramatic.
I love drama.
And you're led through this
visualization ceremony, where
your last day on
earth is simulated,
where you're made to write down
essentially a letter to all
of your loved ones.
You're made to look
at all the ways
that you have wasted your
life, the things you've
done to yourself.
And then ceremonially, you die.
You obviously don't die--
spoiler.
[LAUGHTER]
You obviously don't die.
But when you are
brought back, you
are made to make these
affirmations of things
that you will never do again.
And from that moment,
the first time
I did that process, that was it.
The eating disorder stopped,
because I was able to identify.
I was like, this is
ruining your life.
This is making you
less than who you are.
And that was it.
It stopped.
And it was at that
moment as well,
where I was like,
there's a fight in you.
And you need to bring it.
And that's actually-- from
that moment was when I started
thinking, I need to teach kids.
I need to create a safe
space for children.
I need to create a safe space
for children with disabilities
and teach them.
And when I teach them,
I am unashamedly me.
They know me.
They know that I'm going
to come in in the most
outrageous leggings.
And so will they.
And I love that.
JULIEN FINLAY: Accepting
yourself, and you said.
All right.
More questions, please.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I love the sound
of my own voice.
JULIEN FINLAY: I love it, too.
AUDIENCE: And this is
not even a question.
It's just a comment.
It's just about body positivity.
We had a speaker
here from ShoutOut,
this very important
Irish charity who
do LGBT workshops in schools.
And she had this very
interesting comment a year ago,
where she said she came out
as bi when she was nine.
But she came out
as fat in her 30s,
and to realize that she's not
a thin woman in a fat woman's
body, that this is who she is.
And I think it was a very
important point about that body
positivity often tends to
be about, oh, come here.
You'll get there one day.
We accept all body sizes
that diverge from the norm,
implying there is a norm.
And you know, we tolerate.
But ideally, you should
work with someone else.
And we all, many of us-- god
knows I did-- replicate this
when we congratulate someone
when they lose weight,
like, hey, well done.
Good job.
You're one step closer
to being normal.
And so I guess I just wanted
to echoed that sentiment,
that it's in all these--
I don't want to call
it microaggressions.
But I guess it's all in
these tiny, little steps we
can take with each other
to just be more inclusive.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
I think that's great a point.
I mean, actually, I met
with Bella this week.
I actually had dinner
with her on Tuesday night.
And she did mention
that to me as well,
that of her sort of coming
out moment, not just
as bi, but as a fat person.
And I thought it was
wonderfully inspiring.
So it's given me
food for thought--
food being the operative word.
And yeah, so I'm going
to certainly try and be
a bit more body
positive about myself.
Because this is who I am.
And I don't see why I
should change just to--
being trans is one
thing, because you're
changing your body anyway,
with hormones and blockers.
You can put on
two to three stone
just by taking
estrogen, which isn't
helping me get any thinner.
So I just need to accept
who I am, you know,
and just love
myself for how I am.
JULIEN FINLAY: And you
beautiful as you are.
And we are delighted
having beautiful panels.
Do you want to add
something to that, Finlay,
on body positivity?
Have you already discussed?
You don't have to.
FINLAY WILSON: I
mean, certainly--
I mean, in the yoga world, I
tell all of my students that
buy yoga magazines-- this is
me not going to get my yoga
magazine subscription
or paid from them--
I say to them, it's like,
please stop buying this trash
and actually donate
your money to a charity.
That would be lovely.
Because it is just
adverts of thin women
selling yoga leggings.
And that's all it is.
It's all that it is.
And those of you are like,
oh, no, it's more than that.
It's women selling crystals.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
And the woman
selling the crystals
is also thin and
blonde and perfect.
So it's like, bah.
But what I love is the
yoga studio that I teach
at that I helped set
up, when the people,
when everybody comes to
our studio, everybody
who is anybody, they
come to the studio
because they can do
the class regardless.
It's not like, a, oh, come in.
We'll help you lose the weight.
That isn't the message
they get when they come in.
It's like, come on in.
We'll see what happens.
JULIEN FINLAY: All right.
Do you have any other questions,
anything that's on your mind?
When is the next class?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Laura.
And I have a question, because
I was active for animal rights
some years ago.
And I got a lot of hate from
online and from my friends
as well.
And especially, I
think if you get
this hate from people
you like or your friends,
it's a lot more hurtful.
And I just wanted to know if
you dealt with this as well,
and if you dealt with
it in a different way
than with those
anonymous people online?
FINLAY WILSON: Yeah, totally--
I remember sharing,
I think it was
when I shared about Scotland
getting same-sex marriage.
I shared that.
And one of our friends were
like, this is a travesty.
And I wrote a letter to them.
And I said, look, I
need you to acknowledge
that by saying this, you are
invalidating me as a person.
You're saying I don't deserve
to have the same rights as you.
But you still think
that we can be friends.
I cannot be friends with you if
this is how you're going to be.
I cannot.
I'm not going to whore
myself out so that you
feel more comfortable.
I'm not going to downplay
myself so that you feel better
about yourself.
I'm not doing it, no way.
So get back on there.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
I mean, that's something I'm
struggling with at the moment.
And I have family
members who don't
accept who I am and expect--
they still call me
by my birth name
and won't meet me unless
I'm my former self.
And I've just said, no.
I'm not doing that.
This is who I am.
I've struggled with
this for so long.
And I've come out.
And I'm not going to
go back into that role.
And if you can't
accept that, then we'll
just have to not see each other.
And it's hurtful.
FINLAY WILSON: I would for
you to be part of my life
and accept me for who I am.
And if you cannot do that, then
I'm not going to change for you
to be in part of my life.
It's legit.
I mean, I had some
family members not
show up to my wedding.
And it was like, I hear you.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
This is who I am.
And that's it.
I can't change it.
Or sorry, I can.
But I'm not going to.
FINLAY WILSON:
You are being you.
They are the ones
exerting the choice
to be the bigoted asshole.
JULIEN FINLAY: They
identify as assholes.
That's [INAUDIBLE].
You had a question as well?
Raising hands?
Nodding heads?
AUDIENCE: I, too, love
the sound of my own voice.
No, really quickly, it's
mostly to do with the amount
of attention we give hate.
So I know that
we've spoken a lot,
and the panel has said a
lot, about the comments
they remember, these
hateful, spiteful comments.
But we haven't once
mentioned those good comments
that we do get on those posts.
And is it that really-- and this
is directed to both of you--
that we are giving
too much attention?
We are remembering these posts.
And therefore, we're
glorifying them.
I mean, even with the media,
we have celebrities reading out
mean tweets.
They don't read out the ones
that are nice about them.
So is it that we are
creating this cycle?
Because we are giving too
much attention to those
hateful posts.
And therefore, we're just
encouraging that kind
of negative attention.
FINLAY WILSON: I feel
like the positive--
I aim to acknowledge
the positive as much
as the negative when it
comes in as comments.
Obviously, I will respond to
the positive with a lot more
empathy and kindness.
But the negative, it's that what
we were speaking about earlier.
If we don't address the fact
that the negative is happening,
it's not going to
make it go away.
And if we pretend that
it isn't happening,
then we are complicit.
And I think that's the danger.
Certainly, when people
message me and I ask,
can I share your comment
because it was really lovely,
some [INAUDIBLE]
the right to say--
some say no.
And so I don't get to
share some of that stuff.
So I can't share or
repost a lot of stuff.
But when I can, I do.
But it is that thing of like,
if the negative comes in
and we don't actually address
it, then it does start--
it normalizes that.
And that's, I think, both
of us standing up and being
these voices that
speak out like that.
I want the young kids
that I would teach
to know that that's not OK.
If somebody says
that to them, they're
just going to quietly put it
to bed and then just go home.
It might raise in them
that same fire to resist.
Does that make sense?
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
I think just being nice is
sort of the default position.
I mean, it shouldn't be.
It's not a hard line
to achieve, I think.
And 90% of the
stuff I get online
is positive and is
very, very kind.
And people are very,
very supportive.
It's that 10% of negativity,
where you want to address that.
And you want to say,
look, this is out there.
And if we don't talk about
it or if we don't address it,
it's just going to spread.
And there is the thing
about, again, not
conforming people, not
conforming Nazis and giving
them voices on the
media, and not performing
certain viewpoints is,
I think there is a lot
to be said for that as well,
in that certain things aren't
a debate.
My life is not a debate.
But I think this week on
one of the BBC channels,
there was a guy on who said he
identified as 20 years younger.
And so they had a trans
woman on, debating with him.
I'm going, why are
you doing this?
Why are you equating
this with somebody
who has gender dysphoria?
It's a completely
different issue.
But in the minds of the popular,
they're going, oh, yeah.
If that guy is silly, obviously,
trans people are silly, too.
Because how can you identify
as something you're not?
FINLAY WILSON: I mean, I
identify as a helicopter.
And it's just like, this
is not what is being said,
it's not what is being said.
AOIFE MARTIN: There was an
article in the "Sunday Times"
this week, where Rod
Liddle said, oh, I
want to identify as a
black trans chihuahua.
I was like, all
you're doing is just
saying hurtful things
about trans people
by putting that as an article.
FINLAY WILSON: Acknowledging
that there is--
AOIFE MARTIN: You're
negating our experience.
FINLAY WILSON: --but
also acknowledging
marginalized hurt and
then making fun of it.
AOIFE MARTIN: Yeah.
FINLAY WILSON:
That's really not OK.
So almost thinking about
the negativity, what
was happening in the airport
first thing this morning,
admittedly, it was an ungodly
hour that I was in the airport
this morning.
But a simple act of
speaking out can do wonders.
The simple act of picking
up the trays at security
and putting them back,
because it was backing up
because nobody had
the basic courtesy
to pick up their own damn tray.
So I picked up five
and put them away.
And suddenly, everything
was easy again.
So in the face of an
onslaught of negativity,
if we don't speak out
about it, it mounts up.
And without sounding
militant, they
begin to win because they
don't meet any resistance.
And they expect us to
just quietly resist.
And it's not the time for that.
I mean, rights have been
stripped away in America.
Now if I go into a restaurant
in America with my partner,
they can refuse
service on the basis
that we are a same-sex couple.
That's disgusting.
And what happens in the
States could happen in the UK
just as easily.
These opinions aren't small.
These aren't being said
by insignificant people.
Some of the trolls run
countries, you know?
That's frightening.
And trans rights as well--
there was something
that went out just about
two weeks ago in the States,
where they're saying, actually,
trans people now need
to have a genetic test
to say what their
actual birth gender is
through genetic testing.
JULIEN FINLAY: Focusing on the
right and the good comments
instead of the wrong.
All right.
On this note, so
we come to the end.
We have some bubbles
and non-bubbles
and biscuits and whatever.
They're just waiting for us.
They made a big bang
when I started talking.
Do you have any other questions,
or shall I close this?
Good.
So I'll leave the floor to you
to just give your final words.
You're not going to die
again in shamanic way,
but just to say goodbye.
FINLAY WILSON: You've all
gone through it together.
JULIEN FINLAY: Let's do it.
But anyway, it was a real
pleasure hosting you,
a real pleasure having you.
We discussed education and
how can somehow we prevent
hate before it's already there?
And once it's there, how can
we cope by resisting it and not
just focusing on itself,
not giving it a platform,
but really seeing the other
alternative, like other apps,
or thinking how we
actually all play a role,
like in the airports, lifting
and helping other people?
So thank you again.
We're going to clap once.
We're going to talk and hear
you say your last words.
And we clap again.
[APPLAUSE]
Final words, Aoife?
AOIFE MARTIN: Final
words words of wisdom--
just first of all,
thank you very much.
It's been an absolute privilege
and an honor to be here.
And it's just about
getting voices out there.
And I think I do what
I do because I grew up
with no representation.
And if by what I say
and by what I do,
I can help one young
trans person out
there feel better
about themselves
or feel more accepting
about themselves,
then it's worthwhile.
And that's the only
reason I do what I do.
It's the only reason I speak.
And it's the only reason I talk.
Thank you very much.
FINLAY WILSON: So one of the
motivators behind my actions
on a daily basis,
one of the things
that we instill in the
kids that we teach,
one of the things we instill
in the adults that we teach,
and especially in how they act
when they leave the yoga room,
is to ask the
question, does what
I'm about to do, say, write,
brighten or dim my spirit?
And if you can answer
it, saying that it
is going to bolster you, do it.
If you are swearing
that you're going
to end up like a toxic slime
ball, why are you doing that?
So if you can be
comfortable enough
with yourself to know
that what you are doing,
what your actions are,
are building your energy,
building your life force,
do that thing, creativity,
make things, help people.
But if you start doing something
else, you are damaging.
And be aware of it, because
we're going to get you.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIEN FINLAY: Well, I'm sure
you both brighten up our day.
So thank you and goodbye.
[APPLAUSE]